[Music]
welcome guys to the second lecture today
and this is wrong this is good grammar
so choice about games of the week and
today I'm gonna be talking about two
games from a candidates last time I
talked about freaking from the contest
or gum runs one two three
but right now I'm going to talk about
games four and five around seven four
and five and I pitted with one game each
from each round and in okay I decided to
do this simply because the candidates is
postponed to further unknown date for
now so I thought that as the seven games
were played I covered already first
three rounds and right now covered
second runs four and five and then in
the end I'm gonna cover around six and
seven basically pick my favorite game
from each round so let's get started
with this one and from Round four I read
like the game a maxi marshal de Graaff
versus Alexander Greece Chuck and I
wanted to provide some actually analysis
of this game that I did on my own and I
think it's very instructive simply
because lots of commentators and on the
webpage and the web pages I think ever
many people who looked at this game
missed many details that actually are
important in my opinion so let's let's
see let's see what was going on in this
game he 45 93 96 be should be 596 short
Castle Knight takes e4 d 496 Bishop
takes T 60 takes c6 d takes e5 right of
528 contains the eight
barely endgame nothing new a grid should
be especially Walker's maximovich
Telegraph specialist with white hip I am
like dozens of games in this in this
endgame and right now he very played the
most part of a h3 and they here
Alexander stays I mean like his favorite
line I think in yet after Knight c3 h5
there are other alternatives for
instance Bishop d7 rook g1 Bishop e7 as
for instance it was a game of Sam 7
versus Sam chenkin
into US Championships 2019 also Bishop
e7 gains popularity lately however a
king yet is by far the most popular
lately and this opening this line in the
burning endgame it became popular around
2009/2010 not really sure who exactly
popularized it but I know that a lot of
me Kramnik played in lots of games this
also lots of Chinese grandmasters played
played this line
Hikaru Nakamura lightly plays it almost
exclusively it's very good line I played
myself accidentally she also plays it
many many top grandmasters go for design
game and especially especially this
aching h5 line Bishop F and here Bishop
and for is the main main move another
there are lots of alternatives there's
ninety two very popular line Bishop g5
Ruby 194 to number a few also be free as
possible in random of orders Ruby one
could be possible many many moves but
Bishop f4 stands as the most critical
and sort of cursor as the main tried
Bishop e7 rook 81 Bishop e6 95
and Luke h6 this is the main concept
typical for burb for Berlin Luke because
if let's say black make some random move
let's say I know a 519 c6 f 286 this
structure if white gets bishop on e6 and
forces black to take the pawn is
considered a slightly better for white
and black should usually try to avoid
that
therefore theory goes we should play to
rogue h6 here and here there is
basically main position of the line
because right now there is white has
some choice there is rook everyone move
or D 3 D 3 is the main alternative rock
everyone is the most popular lately
however G freecad was considered at some
point as the main try so let's quickly
have a local happens after a g3 which of
the HD 5 right now is the most popular
response however Bishop c4 was played by
onion theory and the value mu Kramnik it
doesn't 14 and 15 they went for it and
also seems like to me it's pretty decent
line rook e1 or g6 right now at c4 rock
d8 and in and both giving cramming
equalized pretty easy here for instance
rook takes d8 takes takes be free Bishop
g5 see 494 CD CD knight on e4 is hanging
down g5 asking some Knight d6 is
possible but anyway it leads to
simplifications were eventually I think
unusually was game of onigiri and he
onion equalized and made a draw
so it's possible to play Bishop c4 but
main move goes Bishop 335 visual HD 5
which is 6 H 4 idea is that if Bishop H
4 is simply perpetual and there is
nothing what can do really and but after
h 4y it may have some hopes here however
we've correctly if black nose and
usually black goes for they usually they
know takes takes Bishop f4 Knight x h4 f
3 and room T 8 and this is again main
position of this line
it's like lots of fear is very build up
line and it's I it's impossible to cover
it like in one lecture entire line
but anyway rope and there is possible to
play King f2 there is rook takes d8
there is possibility to play route de 1
over a block black holes however black
stones should be a little bit careful
but g3 is one move but Rock everyone has
been considered maybe because
dispositions after G free just to show
quickly both positions are of different
with different color bishops the draw is
tendency are pre high and and the recent
pawns were traded but already black is
pawn up and one is too fun conversation
there have been pretty much worked out
to a draw and I don't want to really
kind of like dive into analysis but
maybe because of that people start to
look for ideas after route 14 look
everyone so what's happened after look
everyone bishop before again white robot
has again huge choice and here maxim
played the most popular lately move a
free and the opinions is very good try
alternatives are not g4 for instance
which is king h2 which which happened in
Caruana and rake in 2014 or Domingues
not like of 2015 but it doesn't really
look dangerous doesn't really create any
thread this is not very forceful idn't
I'm not really sure what it does what
black immediately maybe rope da maybe I
think math 23 here maybe other muscles
also possible but very critical line
here is g4 is this what nvl tried in the
past and the one of the most famous
games in this line is him his game MMVAs
game versus Sergey Karjakin
in Sinquefield Cup 2017 and this game
was very very interesting and very
entertaining if I remember correctly and
VL was playing almost instantly every
single move till the end of the game
well karyakin was spent all his time and
found the best computer moves over the
board of course and made the draw so he
was very entertaining and interesting
let's see how the game went I mean three
four takes takes 97 96 root x e6 King G
to Bishop takes c3 beat XE free root d8
and right now
VL decided to attack to tell you take on
the a group context de draak h 195 and
here he played Bishop g3 very
interesting move basically giving the c3
pawn and going for activity possibly was
also to click in g3 and play rogue h7
could be an alternative not very sure
but Bishop g3 it's possible and after
Luke h6 because the rogue on freddo frog
h7 and maybe a4 a5
look spray annoying cracking same
playbook h6 and try to trade a one pair
of rocks and try to make a draw in the
night versus Bishop versus 9 and game
but this book has been for sure worked
out by
mvl and he took on h6 takes King and
packing each free and he just is going
for the h6 pawn and I just couldn't help
myself as I had to show this game as
talking about this Berlin so let's see
how the game followed because very
interesting nicely freaking age 4 if you
are not familiar of this game
I'm with you if you are watching this
I'll make sure that you know this game
because just so much fun
now it takes I talking age five nights
III King takes age six just ignoring
everything and now right now a cracking
Falls with a five and via Falls with his
bones a four a five a basically pawn
race
kingi HR just trying to make sure that
white bones are not going so quickly up
g5 a free eight six eight - seems like
white black is winning because there is
a queen coming in but not so easy taking
g7 if a one Queen then we can take on f7
therefore take you on f6 is e cigs is
forced f6 a one Queen f7 King the
seventh Bishop f5 I put a double
exclamation mark simply because right
now while black its Queen up but still
has to make find a way to make a draw
and the correcting date but are very my
correct around here killed like three
seconds already or something so anyway
very fun game after Queen e5 Bishop f6
quit c5 it take we have a queen takes
takes 94 threatening basically g7 g8
queen but 494 king of seven-night h g5
sorry correcting gave the night and it
appears that there is it just ends
didn't draw because policy to is not
enough being piece up but having only
policy to is not enough to indicate so
the game followed like this and just
draw but anyway was very spectacular
very interesting and I just had to buy
if talking about Berlin I just had to
show this game quickly so here new idea
a3 and what the and the idea behind the
I mean this avails idea could have been
basically improving Nepos game from run
number two and run number 2 H 4 is
considered best as tough as the for the
fury consider this as the best G for
typical break flow by MV l king edge to
post play by nappa and after King f8
Ruby 1 I don't really like this because
after basic through before I don't know
where it goes but here if he could have
played just three four
I mean or like played night before I
mean and G for a basically such positive
bit Priam similar this is sort of
typical play and some G 4G 3G 4 is
coming maybe try to pull a h4 h5 at some
point as well this looks very sound
seems like what can have some chances
here but here when we all started
immediately changed his I changed I mean
came up the other move and he played g4
this which is typical break for as Arabs
in king h2 and energy for H 3 3 3 4 3 2
3 and this moment grease trucks sank in
fault for like 50 minutes and he played
the most natural move and well it's
crazy simply because grease truck okay
it's he's well known for like thinking
very long time but the thing is that MVA
actually had this positioned in earlier
in his games
namely against Hikaru Nakamura it
doesn't 18 I think and if you are if he
was preparing I will like and playing
this line you should know this game as
well as they were surprising to me that
he was thinking here was surprised by
smoochy for especially it's so typical
okay but okay he played 97 after 50
minutes but anyway
here
h4 was the novelty because I'm Greek for
thinking excel in the interview that it
was in only about g4 and it is of course
the most natural move but you know it
was obvious that VL wouldn't repeat the
previous idea that he had and h4 is very
actually critical is very strong move
very calm very computer-like move but
still it's you should we should be
familiar at least with this move but
here he's start burying the rest of his
time and very good player playing in 3
seconds so and what MVL was still in the
prayer in his prep so h4 and in his game
a previous game and we all played g4 95
Bishop d2 and Rudy elk in g2 Knight b6
and the Hikaru
it was crazy game eventually and in a
draw I think and the Hikaru had very
good position but then it was also blitz
on line so you know in blitz anything
can happen
but anyway h4 is the new move that
basically put big test for black what to
do and to Grich to defend until someone
brilliantly map in 95 attacking this
Bishop and Bishop c1 very interesting
move very again it's prep it's computers
it's it's basically modern chess this
hawk modern chest looks basically
normally people play Bishop me to just
protect the pawn but right now actually
computer suggests there is no necessity
even to care about see free pawn it's
it's crazy because after Bishop d2
honestly I didn't personally see and
don't see anything wrong but you know if
you even don't have to defend this pawn
from like kind of like principle let's
say point of view why to cover your rook
on the one if it's not the is not really
you don't have to work on a text III
wide actually to give why not why to
stop block this Reuben d1 basically it
what may have some idea of maybe
bringing the route D 3 and 3 and this is
what having actually in the game so the
modern approach is just revolutionized
in class let's say regular chess
knowledge it has been for many many
years because normally types of d2 of
obviously just protect the pond maybe
then try to come up with some ideas but
it's not necessary you can purchase up
c1 and also it puts a very difficult
task for Greece chuck because especially
that he was out of book he already
burned so much time and right now he has
to miss the make decision where to
except this pawn sacrifice or actually
do not accept it and what what could be
the refutation so again invites we
should spend even more time so from
practical perspective
Bishop c1 is very very strong move and
he took took took the bait to the
fancy-free but there were alternatives
it was probably more solid to play just
b5 simply because the nagas on d5 is
will be secured c4 would never happen or
at least if c4 c4 then B takes d4 pawn I
don't if I will be still there however
I'm not sure what after after root D 3
IP 6 9 f3 f3
why would still has some pressure in map
in black black is very solid but white
will have some pressure still but this
idea of bishops one group the Filioque
f3 is very important but anyway probably
beef I was a little bit better and going
for this position twice disrupt d8 and
trying to hang on here however position
is very crazy after for instance Knight
active server
possible I want to dive into this line
AB Atlas to basically crazy stuff
this was Albert a better time but let's
see what Griff ship did because not EXCI
free is the most natural move the most
human we just grabbed opponent like why
not there is no immediate refutation of
this so roopd free night 84 if 95 for
instance Rock f1 and rook F free is
coming also c4 is coming so identified
is not worried really well placed and
after 94 rook F 3 and this is I think
the essential idea that and we'll having
had trapped simply because right now
it's difficult to make a move with black
pawn of 7 is weak bishop on e6 is forced
to defend it rook on h8 is a bit awkward
black can never Castle King Johnny and
if black and every Castle King on it
will be also become a weakness not only
for a little bit on this on the edge of
the board and there are ideas of let's
say rook f1 maybe take a look tacking on
e6 and taking on f7 or maybe look a fun
night xf 7 suddenly it's not easy to
face white fret and Grich who doesn't
play by 75 which is very good move
because at least this move attacks the
attacks white rook and put some makes
forces and VL to make a decision here
and I'd be six again Knights if I would
be
and hereafter Roga four if not c5
possibility forest possible I think that
I think that white is having I mean
that's 5 c4 would 93 is not possible but
rook F 1 is doesn't really help
classified or a missus doesn't really
help black so I'm after Knight b6 rook F
1 Ruby g6 the thing is that c4 a after
and c5 could be an idea of c4 but let's
say after this this nitro g6 c4 could be
very strong not Emily because 93 but
like if we can include this c4 is an
idea and i b6 top is this does more than
6 has to be played rook F 1 through g6
again putting the pressure on pongee
free and actively defending pollen f7
because we can take because we obtain G
free but this and right now look f5 and
I'm still sure that it was MVS prep
because if I remember correctly he has
to like 1 hour ferry something maybe he
was remembering a few minutes you
remember the lines but Greece Chuck head
like here like maybe 10 minutes or
something I don't know maybe five
minutes I'm not sure basically almost no
time and here alternative was to play
rook F 2 it looks a bit more passive
rook f5 looks perfectly reasonable
usually when you can take a five rook F
to normal you choose to look at five
because simply more active and creates
more fresh supports also knight on d5 in
case of h5 in some lines it seems like
is just more natural Ruby f5 Bishop c4
again active defense hitting the rook
it's not clear what to do next with drag
because Donovan's hanging
potentially and h5 is coming it's not
easy to abduct to make a move so at
least you do create some threats Bishop
c4 trying to deserve the mobility of
white rocks because a ruby one is that
will want to be hanging on the
on e7 f7 anymore so this gives some time
for black and the best move because
after Luke f2 there could be some of
that group d8 and the rogue d1 coming in
of the counterplay
that's why rook e1 is forced and after
King g7 trying to stabilize bring the
maybe rook to age eight eight five and
until this moment Grisha defended
perfectly but right now he made a little
bit impulsive move because he played
Luke h6 and I think since now this
position basically goes like South I
mean very very quickly and this just
shows how tactical dispositions if you
make one mistake Oleg is just fall wrong
idea it's very very easy to go wrong all
the way basically
and after the best one was here Bishop
e6 and the main difference is that after
Francis rook age 6
g4 Bishop e6 Bishop e6 look there is
move rook at 4 in here this rook on f4
exist and the rook supports pawn on d4
and most but most importantly 94 is not
possible because after Knight c4 will be
the Ruby night x e6 and white simply
wins the piece because I don't see four
be unprotected but
if black star with Misha p6 the rube
Arouca fork here is not possible anymore
because of th g5 therefore what has to
move the rook back to f2 for instance
and now after rook h 6h g 4 there is
move Knight to c4 this is the it's
extremely subtle but that's how it just
works it does very concrete game and
something just something just more
something just don't work and especially
if the in the computer era it's it's
very hard I mean to face preparation
like this if you know Bishop what's the
difference you start Bishop e6 or you
just play rogue h6 look a chick seems
more natural here because you know
rubies under attack why do you even
bother improvements like Bishop e6 seems
like only move you don't kind of like
register Bishop aces that exists you
think about later play h6 fer make a
move and look at 6 first then make a
move and then think but that's how
modern it just works right now Bishop e6
is just very strong and it could
potentially solve all the problems
because after Luke f28 6 Ruby 2 3 4 94
sound designer super is very active and
may offer enough compensation for the
kind of like positional defects on the
King side because with let's say rook
rook F ef-1 Ruka fate takes takes Bishop
g5 f 6 so it is Daniel c4 attacks on a3
also design on c4 prevents a for Bishop
e3 ideas it does lot of defensive tasks
that offers black very very good chances
to survive this
however Grisha papers rook h6 after b3
for his position is very dangerous and
right now he makes me mad further
mistake and this is the mistake
basically that losses actually or nearly
loses because after this move rook h8
of course I understand he goes in time
travel and it's understandable to pace
it come but basically try to get out
with his roof from this Bishop on c1
logical very logical I agree but
this move basically nearly loses it's
crazy to think about the new rules but
this is the truth that nearly loses and
this is the mistake that makes his
position that bad not his later moved at
night ex a for which he played which was
highly criticized or my knowledge at
least and I know that he was like and
several sources were claiming this as a
mistake yes it was maybe a blunder but
anyway position was not not good anymore
and it's how it's hard to in my opinion
to Chris as this move so much and in my
opinion the move that was a bad move
here it was okay J and this is where
this work he went wrong because okay
rogue aged six you can make a mistake
his car transom but Luca is this
basically a big mistake because here he
got to go again we should be six this
bishop belongs to his six in Berlin in
general so we just have to bring it back
bring it back home sort of and Ruger
four yes Knight c4 is now is it's not
possible right now but still you have to
try to sort of hold this nicely for is
impossible but you still can try to hold
this with maybe playing for instance I
know ninety-five b5 for instance 95 and
b5
looks pretty reasonable and try to
maintain design on d5 and create some
maybe play look maybe create some ideas
like this or maybe afraid prepare maybe
95 done and based on g4 it's not over
it's definitely what in charge but his
first term initiative but it's not over
but after Luke H is simply nearly over
because after a for Bishop a free is
coming and there is no way actually to
stop that
and here this move Knight X therefore
this is the move I was talking about a
little bit earlier that was kind of
considered as big mistake at losing move
but to be honest black is already nearly
lost if black can hold somehow with by
suggested why they suggested me should
be six
if Black has survived is this by pure
miracle and according to my analysis
it's very unlikely that black would
survive this with correct play by white
for instance night xe6
it was anyway Bishop e6 will have to be
played it was the best defense but just
to show how terrible blacks position is
I'll let me just show following lines
night 86 if F takes c6 Ruby g5 King gave
seven rook f1 Kimi g8 Ruby g6 rook e8
Bishop g5 suddenly h6 Bishop FC is
coming I know really see at the fest
because of King eternal rock f7 seems
like game over so you can take up the
pawn on e6
if you take the King kinesics rook F 1
and there is no of stopping rook takes
f7 because Luke f8 would be met by
Bishop e3 there is no way to establish
the rotates of 7 and you've looked as a
rookie rook a e8 rook takes f7 let's say
he's seven trying to soul make it solid
on the seventh rank look at five and
suddenly Luke g5 v g6 comes in King is
in big danger usually the big problem is
in the big problem Berlin that white
cannot really make use of the pawn
majority on the King side right now
since I was born
our postpones are just marching forward
punch them is just very weak qualifies
the past pawn is not weak points the
past bones very strong past bone
seems like again what is nearly winning
here for instance this 94 which is 5
rook h6 rook f8 idea ROG hitting on g7
forcing let's say rook h7 the new g6
simply very very unpleasant position for
for black possibly just lost very likely
lost another move 97 for instance trying
to bring the knight to the game somehow
and maybe hit on e5 this point 5 let's
say rook I take the southern route 88
King G to let's say rook a f8 and the
going even for this and game is very
dangerous because here
it's impossible to defend pot very
likely because this these two pawns are
basically marching forward the support
of the king and the bishop hitting on
this pawn I don't think black can
survive this either taking only five it
doesn't really work because we should be
to always even Knight takes d5 Bishop b2
and drinking a four and for instance
this we should be two for instance and
it's impossible to hold on to the g7
pawn because after King F for design I
would be kicked out of there of this
diagonal point just won't be lost and
there are no any jumps from this night
so I think it just came over and yeah so
this is basically it it's very unlikely
that Bishop e6 would save the game
either way it was possibly the best
defense
but anyway position is very likely lost
so I will increase the risk for night
except for so much I think if anything
was pretty decent try simply because a
gives white choice and and we all went
immediately wrong because he played
Bishop afraid the most let's say natural
move to just you know a full plate that
I hope is a free tract but right now it
doesn't work
rookie for as everyone probably knows
was winning but I just want to give this
inside that night XA 4 is not such a bad
move the such a bad move that was but
I'll go through age 8 and from here all
the real problems began but Bishop but I
mean here had to be Bishop e6 but a
rocket ride a four position is already
on the verge of defeat
so Bishop e6 possibly was the best
chance but it was not easy at all and
possibly you just lost either way so
Knight takes d4 yes rookie 4 is very
nicely winning for instance let me just
repeat the move the lines that everyone
knows let's say we shot a c6 Knight
takes c6 pawn takes Bishop g5 King here
Drogo 395
Ruger 4 and rogue f7 comes in game over
if 96 we shop a freaking g8 Knight takes
f7 and e-cigs is coming game over again
and if b5 very nice idea
rook takes c4 takes seven and rotate
seven simply dominating over on the
board
96 Bishop a3 tackle on g7 many things
are just simply winning four for a while
here so that's what winning yes Rotech
c4 was winning but this move of krishna
is before it shouldn't be you know so
criticized so much in my opinion
so bishop a free and will miss his
chance sort of what happened but bishop
a free have automatically played i
assume because seems like automata move
just give check it and think but c5 and
suddenly it's not so easy because after
ruby for right now it's not so easy
anymore because Bishop takes Bishop d6
and michigan see when is much better
place involves lines rather than a free
for instance group a4 is already really
suspicious it's not sure who's put
better here probably even black could be
better
two pawns and postponed with v e5 a5 r
we can identify it's under attack team
black thing is very safe and i think
back is doing great if Knight takes c6
takes root g5 now Knight c3 actually
this is what a grito suggested in the
interview after the game and it seems to
work pretty nicely for for black because
Roxy for Knight d5 only move which would
Lexie [ __ ] f7 Ruger for King g8 and
suddenly black sort of holds no not
clear what what can do next at least I
don't listen
kind of like clear idea what to do next
Luke fc0 creator which is rogue age
seven maybe I don't know seems like
maybe than age six maybe maybe still
there are some some problems going to
forgive six everything over right now
but the rogue f6 on the other hand could
be made by Knight c3 so it's very
unclear and I'm not sure whether it's
it's winning or whether it's even better
for it having said I maybe I'll try
ESA's which is very nice practical try
after f6 Bishop takes t59 text e5
to a c5 and but this already is very
close to drawing here I I like glitch
tubes approach because he just took on
five and from practical perspective is
the having especially 30 seconds or like
one minute on the clock
ingot time trouble it seems like very
very natural way of defending simply
simply simplify the position and try to
escape in the rook endgame and this is
exactly what happened the game so the
rest is I think of the last importance
there were alternatives those possible
to play be five or six as well for
instance be five Roxy seven king the 637
king c6i the free bishop 36 which is 75
but this requires calculation and
requires evaluation as well and having
30 seconds it's not easy to to assess
this position especially having here
postponed on it five policies could
become a weakness could be lost
eventually like it's most likely fine
but why to bother sort of us believe we
have 30 seconds so I perfectly
understand bishops approach physics was
also possible but again very unclear
whether this end game is Hall double
probably this because actually I could
even though why the exchange up there
black has to pause and the likelihood of
trading pulls pond on the Kingston is
pre hi mapping and first pawns are
traded will be very lucky at draw it was
also possible but why to bother
basically if you can escape to rock and
game the loops just very nice after move
like here a5 which is important move
because by pushing this upon white black
creates a counter play and deflects
white rocks and in general white action
from pushing support and a pawn and
supporting it or maybe collecting these
pawns on the King side and with a5 a3 a4
a3 black Austin what Webber I mean white
has to also watch on this upon and make
to make sure that it's not running away
and ever I mean since now position is
pretty much equal and
see how the game finished Rudy what
happened before could have been a little
bit more accurate but after Ruby g8 very
cool move
I don't see why black should have any
reason to worry
a for a freeze coming and they -
supposedly
some some lines like this are possible
of course require calculation but
objective it is something like this
should be preferred draw Ruby one a
kinky seven happen in the game and there
is nothing simply for white and the game
just ended in a draw so it just quickly
look aged six I remember correctly and
we also in the game that he couldn't
find anything here so we just decided to
make a drug here already it was just
probably a good call simply because this
point I for is very annoying so this
what happened and this is just a dead
drop the same game and this is how the
game ended
so quite bad result for M via but never
does he show great preparation and I
think that Grich was under big pressure
and but nevertheless Greece should be
criticized for this move Knight takes a
four but grew cage okay J because this
was actually actual an actual mistake
but anyway over the board it's all very
hard to figure out and we can only thank
Volvo of them for very entertaining and
very fun game for because for our
spectators it's definite that was
definitely very interesting so let's
let's go quickly to show alligator
heading prepare for today a new Pavan
cow we don't have time for this
all right so we don't have time
unfortunately for this today
we will get back to this game next time
and next week I'm gonna we're gonna for
sure cover the rest game from the
contest from each round and this will
game will be include this game next week
I will cover definitely definitely
against van Cao and I will I haven't
decided yet but I'll pick one one game
from round number six and round number
seven and total three games and
hopefully we will make up for the time
that we unfortunately do technologies
have to spend today a lot lose today but
next week we'll make up for this so
thank you guys I guess for for today and
I'll see you next time
[Music]